efficace à un niveau très élevé contre
la nouvelle souche sont les propos de
Vladimir Poutine le président russe qui
déplorent toutefois le taux trop bas de
personnes vacciné en Russie les
explications avec notre correspondance
depuis Moscou vs Man
alors que le vaccin russe peine à
trouver sa place en Europe occidentale
et les saluer par l'ensemble de la
Communauté des États indépendants tu es
sûr et efficace contre la nouvelle
souche du coronavirus a déclaré Vladimir
Poutine lors d'une réunion des chefs
d'État de la C8 le président russe à
déplorer que seulement 56 % des
personnes sois immunisé en Russie et non
pas 80 % comme conseiller par les
scientifiques je propose d'écouter
[Musique]
il m'a dit que ça peut donner la réponse
finale à la question de savoir dans
quelle mesure mets le niveau de
neutralisation est très élevé
il y a 2 jours
sont actuellement en Russie a
enregistré en novembre
dernier jour